hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about what to do for a hiatal hernia
okay this is a really powerful technique
you can give someone a lot of relief
really fast hiatal hernia is a situation
where your stomach is actually bulging
up through the diaphragm okay so right
through here it's kind of coming up and
creating a lot of congestion right here
and the valve doesn't close and you have
stuff regurgitating back through here
you can call that GERD but the point is
that you need some relief right in
addition that you know regular
increasing of upside of vinegar and
things like that there's a manual
technique that you can do now right
right in the center right below my rib
cage right in the center okay you have
the sternum that comes down here there's
a little piece of cartilage you don't
want to press right on that okay so
that's like right in the center you want
to do massage to the right of it and to
the left of it so the ribs come down
through here
okay so right underneath your ribs as
you come right up through there you want
to press at an angle one at a time press
right up underneath into this angle
right through here to the midline and
you just want to press there now if you
a lot of you have massage too and you
can use the longer version as a tool
massage tool to kind of gently press and
hold up into that area right here now
you're going to feel that's just going
to be tight there's there's probably a
lot of muscle guarding in there but
you're going to press this very gently
and hold this for like one to two
minutes okay and you're going to feel
this it's going to relax what we're
trying to do is take this congestion and
push it back down through here okay so
now we'll take it to the other side and
angle right in there so you'll now
you're going to come this side come up
into that center part right through here
and right out in the rib cage you press
underneath here if you don't have this
you can use your thumb and you press in
there gently and just hold okay and you
can go left and right massage and you're
gonna be fine as long as you don't press
on the midline so you want to come off
the midline so you don't wanna hit that
cartilage and again since you're
pressing in there you're not going to
overdo it you're just going to massage
this area
and you're just gonna create a lot more
space so the food can actually come down
here and that valve can closed very
simple technique again you start on one
side right underneath the rib cage about
let's say about one to two inches to the
right press up in in there and you're
you're pressing up at an angle right
into the diaphragm and you're just
holding and pressing and kind of
massaging through there to your own
tolerance relax it then do the other
side and you can do this just once a day
for one to two weeks and you're going to
find that you're going to decongest this
area and allow just like any muscle
that's in a tight knot you're going to
allow the muscles to have the proper
tone because you have a lot of muscles
in this area and to normalize all right
so go ahead and comment below and share
your experience when you do this
technique so I want to know what you're
interested in as far as a video click
the link down below and share some ideas
I want to hear